Any thoughts on B-pollin for boosting immune system?
Well, I'm a huge fan of B-pollin.
So B-pollin is great, this is, to me, B-pollin isn't a supplement.
B-pollin is a food, so there's no negatives for B-pollin.
You only have to be careful with any, like you're talking about immune
to boost it.
Just remember that if you have an autoimmune disease to, in your boosted, your immune system,
too much, you could end up with flares of your autoimmune disease.
So if you want more data on that, go to the chronic disease at autoimmune course.
So remember, we're trying to keep a balance with the numbers of supplements that we're giving
to a person because we don't want other issues to come up.
We also realize that it's a pretty good chance that most people have an autoimmune disease
that maybe hasn't been diagnosed yet.
So I'm not against trying things, just be aware that things could flare and if you take
more immune stimulants than you need, you could be flaring an autoimmune issue.
So just keep that in mind.